The Joe Rogan experience.
I think if there's a real concern about Ai,
I think the real concern is AI is going to rationally analyze our behavior and
our reliance on emotions and all these human rewards systems that we have built
in the way it's affecting our society and the way it's affecting how we govern
ourselves and how we behave amongst ourselves.
And it's gonna think we're unfixable.
It's going to look at it like,
well,
this is,
they have too much monkey in them.
They have so much monkey instincts and monkey DNA.
But now they live in this rational,
modern world of,
you know,
five g internet on your phone and satellite communication and 24,
seven news cycle.
But yet they have these primate jeans
officially intelligence,
uh,
subjects about,
which I know very little seems to me that it would on some level behalf to be
derived from a particular aspect of human understanding of rationalism.
So we're represent in one aspect of our nature and prioritizing it.
Logic,
uh,
organization.
But what you refer to is sort of primitive and monkey ish for me envelops and
involves the most beautiful aspects of our nature.
I'm a little romantic about human being still.
I still feel that.
I feel that one of the great problems we've had is that philosophically we have
overvalued materialism rationalism and like kind of knowing a little bit about
philosophy primarily from that bloody podcast that you and I tagged a minute ago
before we was recording.
Who's that as far as this.
So like what,
why understand for that?
He's like punished enlightenment.
We've started to prioritize rationalism.
So if you prioritize rationalism and organization,
which obviously has a lot to offer,
the organization of resources is incredibly in,
hugely important.
You forget that a huge part of the human experience is nothing to do with that.
The other thing we were chatting about before we went live with DMT now know
artificial intelligence is going to understand that there is access to a realm
of consciousness that continually exists that doesn't seem to be bound by
physical laws as we understand them.
And if the physical laws that we abide by our parochial and relevant only to
this level of existence,
why are we allowing ideas,
resources from there to govern all of our systems.
You know,
it will even listen to you talk about the empty and you know,
I encountered these gestures.
I their gestures are went through this membrane into another realm and checking
out Mike Tyson when he was on here.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
I love that moment was so amazing.
Like a clear like you know,
I only,
I took acid when I was a teenager and even in very unhealthy can,
no,
I'm healthy but Blatt,
unbridled,
mad teenage boy conditions.
I,
you know,
I want to be there with a guy in a lab coat with a pen and going,
well Mr Brian,
sit down and look at these Rorschach tests instead of which I'm in new cross,
in a bed set,
dropping acid and staring at my own hands and recognizing,
oh my God,
I am not me.
The very idea of me as a construct,
I'm just tuned into a particular aspect.
I AI,
we'll build a systems that are,
that are predicated on rationalism organization and I uh,
on on,
on that basically I can see why they would at some point.
Yeah,
go all sky net and then I lay us.
But that is,
I believe the problem with our society is that the materialistic aspect of our
nature is not the priority.
It's just one thing we should be doing because we need good roads,
calls me in the hospitals,
schools,
food,
et cetera.
But we need to find a way of honoring the sacred.
And I'm fascinated in the experiences you're having in these psychedelic
explorations and how it's influencing the rest of your life.
Like how you're saying like how your,
how does it influence the rest of your decisions,
the way you see the world,
the way you see relationships,
the way you see the vulnerable young man you were prior to building your own
Isay personal religion of Marcia Lars,
excellence in your chosen field of standup comedy.
How do you incorporate that vulnerable kid?
Cause I'm still very aware of the vulnerable person.
I was like,
I'm going on a rant man.
Um,
like when Kevin Hart was on here who I think he's amazing and he was amazing on
this,
I fought fucking know like,
well I've,
I've got to offer the world when Kevin Hart has got this kind of force,
you don't come in the bubble.
And not while I was like,
my God,
this guy is so positive.
What a role model while he's got to offer.
And then I thought,
well like any of us,
well I've got to offer is who I am.
Just who I am as a vulnerable floors,
human being.
There's still feels connected to the kid I was when I didn't feel good enough.
I still feel that I can walk in a room and filled out.
But I also know that,
that that's not real because I've had spiritual experiences,
hallucinogenic experiences that make me feel that the relationships we should be
building half the honor,
that we are both,
we are vulnerable and flawed,
but also capable of greatness.
There has to be room for all of this.
And I feel that part of what we're doing and part of why we're experiencing such
superficial polarity in politics and culture,
it's cause we're not acknowledging that underneath this surface activity of
left,
right,
right.
And you know,
from Sam Harris,
them little experiments,
you stick garbage in front of a pest.
I'm on there.
They become Republican pretty quickly.
Or You,
you know,
you scare people,
they become less democratic.
You know,
I think all that stuff is pretty superficial and at depth in that realm of the
gestures and the membrane of Psychedelia,
we have access to oneness and that should be what's influencing the way we set
up our tribes,
our systems,
and our relationships.